حذر مدير وكالة المخابرات المركزية من
أنه قلق من
أن بوتين قد يستخدم سلاحًا نوويًا تكتيكيًا
في هذه المعركة ، هل أنت قلق
ليس أنا فقط أعتقد أننا في
جميع أنحاء العالم يجب أن نكون
قلقين
لأنك تعلم
أنه يمكن أن يكون غير حقيقي  معلومات
ولكن يمكن أن تكون الحقيقة صحيحة لأنهم عندما
بدأوا يتحدثون عن
أه معارك أو معارك أخرى أو أه تتضمن
أعداء أو أسلحة نووية أو
كيميائي بعض المواد الكيماوية تعرفون
أنها أسلحة كيماوية يجب أن يفعلوها يمكنهم فعل ذلك
أقصد لذلك هم  يمكن بالنسبة لهم
حياة الناس لا شيء
لهذا يجب أن نفكر
لا أه لا
تخافوا أعني أن لا تخافوا كونوا مستعدين
لكن هذا ليس السؤال
لأوكرانيا وليس فقط لأوكرانيا
للجميع أه  لكل العالم أعتقد ذلك